dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
今まで何回か外来語について話したことはあるが今日は外来語ではなく
イング一緒について動画を作りたいと思うまずはそう
外来語と淫具淫手は違う根本的に違う
外来語は日本語になった外国の
言葉で ingress は単純に間違った英訳であるだから英語を母語とする人から
したら外来語が不自然だとしてもそれが日本語になっているので実は全然不自然では
ない
不自然なのはパイオニアスピリットみたいな言葉を日本語の文書に入れようと思った
日本人だ
だから術に綺麗な言語があるのに
んでスーパー苦労日目ちょっと話がそれちゃった陰部人は単純に間違ったいい訳
もしくは不自然な英訳でやるしかし english の何が面白いかというと間違っ
ているからではなく間違え方が近所だからである日本在住の外国人ならわかると思うが
ing しか入ることによって日常的な説明文やポスターなどが実存的な
しになる僕はこの独特でシュールの文書が実はとても好きなので今日はオリジナル
イング一生いくつか作ってみたいと思う
トイレの壁に貼り付けられた髪
トイレの利用法にプッシュ目ぱしず
じゃない女子中学生向けのノートの表紙 abdb グルー
ベビーグリーンちょんくんイーズグリーンブルー
カーズトゥーンファー
fall さあですデパートにある靴屋の名前中
根太がですタバコのマナー広告 d アッシュ4 my finger ster 処分
breeze
我過ごす毎日車 a 5塾の広告が5人乗得てがねぇ
瓜生が異常ポイント
ドリーマーズハイスコアのピザ屋さんのメニューもしくは ev の説明
4サイズの rj ハーフハーフニール造形 firehouse フリーそう選手
pi ro se
ダウン4 nd to do
web す産品ウェディング bearded vivi モデルの sns 投稿ん
tree with my fashion ピンクパーコールヌードポスター
本近い温泉の入り方
tko rx アーリーフォールドハはロニーマスターズ dx ワールズオウム
burberry scarf ミニフィグセンス p ポーター to do in
ファミレスの名前
ロンジン
ゲームのカットシーンウォーズ den with finger 分
サーモンサーバースターバー
ああああいう点と年
大妖精里はいつ外すの
ワールド wave me
me